ich weiß sie das geld befördert ich
glaube man tut dem film logan lucky von
steven soderbergh nicht unrecht wenn man
ihn als unterhaltungsfilm bezeichnet als
gangster komödie aus der klassischen
tradition des amerikanischen kinos der
film spielt in der amerikanischen
tiefsten provinz im südwesten im north
carolina und in west virginia und
erzählt von lauter verlierern die
endlich das große ding drehen wollen und
auf die sonnenseite des lebens gelangen
wollen
hier ist das wichtigste rennen des
jahres
dieser soll ein überfall aber ein großes
rennen stadion in north carolina sein wo
jährlich die nasca rennen ausgetragen
werden und beteiligt daran sind zwei
verschiedene familien von denen die
einen sozusagen die katze des
unternehmens und die anderen die
handwerker stellen was schon die rufen
passen uns die minenarbeiter weil wir
uns auskennen
weil ihr euch gut auskennt nur dass
einer der von daniel craig gespielt wird
der eigentliche safeknacker erst aus dem
gefängnis befreit werden muss damit
wiederum den überfall der raubzug
stattfinden kann
das sind eine überraschung ich kann so
laut sagen
ich habe es nicht gesehen wie geht so
tja ich sitze auf dieser seite vom tisch
und hat einen strampelanzug an wie sie
als mir da schon groß gehen
soderbergh hat es in den letzten jahren
immer wieder zu erkennen gegeben dass er
eigentlich vom hollywood system die nase
voll hat dass er nichts mehr zu tun
haben will mit den großen studios mit
dem mainstream und vor fünf jahren hat
er sogar erklärt dass er vollkommen
aufhören wolle mit dem kino was er
natürlich wie man sieht nicht
durchgehalten hat gibst du mir bitte
meine hand nach vorne
[Musik]
es gehe so der bank wollte immer
gleichzeitig dazu gehören und nicht dazu
gehören ihr wollt ein autorenfilmer
seien mit blick nach europa und er
wollte ein richtiger amerikanischer film
zähler seien in logen lucky ist ja vor
allem rechte die bis zum tresor weiß
dass man sich mit seiner 31
was jetzt 20 oder 30 wir haben sie mit
wissenschaft zu tun und weil soderbergh
auch noch ein besonders gutes
schauspielerensemble für diesen film
versammelt hat fehlt eigentlich wenig um
diese komödie zu einer der großen kino
ereignisse des jahres zu machen
[Musik]